good to see you nice to see you um i'm
just going to start with congratulations
on hot zone i finished it um actually
this morning and i thought you did
excellent
thank you you watched something's
episodes i did
wow
yeah i don't [ __ ] around i don't [ __ ]
around when i'm talking to you
i go full force um so so i have a few
few questions to ask before getting an
full g-force from the look of your
background oh there we go exactly by the
way i keep it here because i figure it's
such a great uh property an ip how can
they not be making it
that's that's a really good question yes
that's a very good question i might have
to look into that
i by the way you should because first of
all it has a great title either geforce
or battle of the planets with vfx now
the fiery phoenix come on like
it's
it's a no-brainer so yes
i i've
i've watched so many episodes of that
along with uh star blazers those two
remember that dude if i if i had the
space the yamato would be right behind
me that that's that was that's a badass
spaceship oh dude hi we're on the listen
we're on the exact same page and that's
another thing even though in japan
they're making all of the star blazers
stuff
it's just another one of those
properties that i think could do so well
if done right
great story
well you know what
you got my producer you made me put my
producer hat on the cogs are turning
yeah all i'm saying is if you end up
making either i definitely want a signed
poster
so one of the things uh i'm curious if
someone has never seen anything that
you've done what's the first thing you
want them watching
i've never been asked that question
before
uh
wow
i guess lost
i guess but
even that it would have to be a
qualified answer because you know i
would want someone to see me speaking
english um
maybe this
um
i'll say for the sake of this interview
the hot song
completely um before i get into hot zone
because obviously i have like 17
questions um i
what is it like having voiced an
animated character in avatar the last
airbender and now being asked to play
such a big role in the live action
uh you know i
i feel like it
it's uh it keeps me in the family you
know uh
it's it's funny that
uh that how many times i would get phone
calls from
friends kids when they would hear me
they would hear my voice in avatar and
it showed me you know how popular that
that show was among a certain
demographic
and and so when it came time to decide
whether to do the live action series
uh i called all of my friends kids and
my nieces and nephews and asked them
whether they think i thought i should do
it and they and before i even got the
question that they were like yes i was
like but wait a minute before you answer
just know i play
a bad guy and they're like ozai i was
like yeah
do it you know so it was never there was
no hesitation whatsoever and so
it made it easy for me to say yes and
and you know make my nieces and nephews
and my kids happy
i'm very excited for that um when do you
actually start filming do you know
uh the
the i think production starts uh in a
couple of weeks
oh wow
um i cannot wait um i have so many other
questions on that but i will jump into
hot zone um one of the things i think
the series does so well is capture that
that that time after 9 11 where everyone
was scared of everything and we were not
sure what could happen tomorrow can you
sort of talk about that yeah i mean it's
something i've talked about a lot today
you know like
it was really the first time that we as
americans experienced
a significant terrorist attack on on our
soil and so
uh i think it was foundation shaking um
you know in more ways than one uh and
then you know and you're absolutely
right there was a lot of uncertainty
there was a lot of fear uh there was a
lot of looking for answers immediately
and you know
and as a result scapegoating people and
and and you know countries and so
uh
it was it really
it really i think
shook us in a way that i hadn't seen in
my lifetime and then the anthrax attacks
happened happening just a few weeks
later was
just kind of deep in this sense of
vulnerability and and that was actually
um
something that i tapped into to start
playing this character
what's interesting about your role is
that you are playing someone who's
desperate to find the truth but you
don't even have the time to deal with
your own ptsd on what's happened to you
um and so i mean that must have been
actually very challenging as an actor
and also very enticing to do can you
can you sort of talk about that
for sure you know i think what what
really helped me um
kind of explore that aspect of the
character was actually talking to
real fbi agents who were working in new
york at the time of uh the towers
falling they told me that
they would work 12-hour shifts during
that time because and no one was
no one was taking a break they would
work 12-hour shifts and then when they
were done they were going to ground zero
and helping to search for bodies helping
in any way they could and they were
doing that for another 12 hours these
agents not just one
more than one told me that they were
they did not sleep for two weeks after
that like
just non-stop work because that's how
dedicated they were
so when you when when you're talking
about riker and and you know his own
mental health issues it's
he was of a mindset that everything was
going to take a back seat um to to
finding out
who perpetrated these crimes
including his mental health his his love
life his family his parents his family
his nephews you know and so this was
this
it meant it kind of i think the show did
a really good job of portraying the
dedication and the persistence that that
riker had
a hundred percent um what what was it
like actually behind the scenes the
making of the series is there anything
that you think might like surprise
people to learn i like learning that
kind of stuff
sure it would surprise you to learn that
that when we were pretending that we
were outside in florida it was
like five degrees below zero in toronto
canada uh and we were shooting in the
middle of uh
uh a major extreme covered lockdown and
uh
and there were times we actually had to
stop shooting because there was too much
snow
[Laughter]
so
we had a blizzard in in the middle of
may uh in in toronto and i was out there
with just a suit jacket on so that was
that was that there's a little behind
the scenes for you
first of all i don't know well i mean
there's no such thing as climate change
and global warming clearly
clearly
you know snow in toronto and may what
yeah yeah you know that it's run of the
mill
you know that that's ridiculous um talk
a little bit about if you don't mind
like when you have a big scene on say a
monday a very emotional very dramatic
scene and you're a little in your head
about it how early on are you breaking
it down as an actor in terms of getting
ready to do something i'm fascinated by
how actors their process i'm just
curious how you get ready for something
that you know is going to be challenging
i like to prepare as much as i can and
so
when um when
one of the best things about
the way this show shot was that all the
scripts were done before we we shot even
the first episode there were more
changes on this show that then i'd ever
seen before um but
i could arc
the journey of the character from
episode one through episode six so if i
had an emotional scene i could i could
see where that scene fell in the context
of the full character where as on a show
like lost where we were kind of learning
what our you know the fate of our
character episode the episode it was
harder to do
so
um i always like
i would rather be over prepared than
underprepared and because you can take
your preparation and throw it out the
window on the day uh in the name of
spontaneity but if you have not done the
work then
then there's there's nothing you can do
on the day to make up for that
no completely um so my last thing for
you uh you have some really uh fun
scenes with tony that are towards the
end of the series um can you sort of
talk about getting to work with him
because it's really building for four
episodes to you guys finally sitting
across each other you know at a table
thank you for asking that you know one
of the best parts of this experience was
working with tony i thought that he was
not just incredibly
easy to work with
offset
off camera but he was
such a professional onset and
those two scenes that we had were a
couple of the highlights of of my time
you know michael caine says you know
they don't pay me to act they pay me to
wait um uh and i act for free you know
the way i felt on that day was that i
wasn't working it was it was a joy and
it was so much fun you know in that
and that i was engaged fully as an actor
and
it was because of the quality and
strength of his work
i gotta stop there i'm just going to say
it's always a pleasure to talk with you
thank you for giving me your time and i
really am uh i mean avatar i can't wait
you know
well make sure we talk then uh when that
when that drops
dude i'm very excited i really am and
honestly if they do it right it could be
a huge huge series
we'll see fingers crossed
you